[Applause]
oh yeah you see that
tackle pull off thank you 77 just put me
on my eyes
i'm gonna put the dagger in here i'm
gonna make him wish he never said no
anything is possible bills have won it
they're advancing to the afc
championship game always put the money
on me welcome to the playoffs baby
hey these games ain't for everybody's
game for the elite just give it all you
got
what a matchup we have for you here
today at lambeau field to kick off the
divisional
playoff weekend the number one offense
against the number one defense
super excited to be here
[Music]
then what we've been missing yeah
see what we've been missing right here
heavy underdogs we're just gonna let it
all hang out today
make sure you go wherever i go straight
victory bruh we
go three two three live from new york
baby it's saturday night
a showdown of young quarterbacks lamar
jackson josh allen
hey nobody on this still stop you bro
from salt lake city
kansas okay
let's
the browns last week no one gave him a
chance against pittsburgh
kind of same feeling this week right
this is against the champs
here we go i know y'all looking for me
i'm here
i'm here hey we trying to work we at
work right now
we just caught you know what keep the
camera on me dawg cause they
i'm going crazy we know about drew but
the guy that's crashed the party
on the nfc side is tom brady it's the
best seat in the house
you ain't amped up right now for this
check game hopes 18 weeks ago we stood
right here
against this team we talked about being
warriors but one way or the other
that's what you are that's who you are
that's what we are let's go get a win we
don't drink water win
play our football babies on only way to
do it
i ain't trying to go home i ain't trying
to go home damn now i ain't trying to go
home
devonte goes in motion to the right
quick talk davonte's got it
and the rams got crossed up on the
motions steel and ramsay
you got bird hey hell yeah hell yeah
hell yeah i want him if he goes
[Applause]
we have to get worse
hey come on now you know what i'm coming
now lj
reverse goes to jamis and they got a man
wide open trey quan smith
jameis winston with a touchdown pass
against his former team
to take the lead good triggering to get
us on the board
they're gonna run a sprint option
touchdown
kansas city he throws it up into the
third
deck well whoever caught it giving it
back that's why we love him
cause he's doing it all julie whatever
you see man
i have complete confidence man i got you
first rogers
fakes the handoff bootleg's right pump
fakes once and again takes it himself to
the end of
touchdown oh week off your packages
you'll be scared your defensive number
one demon
but look at your balls now
good job oh i didn't mean to click over
i
i was so excited comes back to the near
side a man wide open at the five
stumbling for the pilot
and fumbled out of the end zone it'll be
a touch back upstairs
no it's out it's that that's a touchback
31-yard attempt for justin tucker the
most accurate kicker in
nfl history and it hits the left up
right
and it is no good
[Applause]
a brilliant catch and run by the best
tight end in the league
let's go man set him in baby
hey down that thing up quick throw here
to the outside and in for the touchdown
go stefan
diggs yes let's go
[Applause]
who's going to be the guy to break them
loose who's going to be the guy to make
the difference
big deal play action fake looks throws
corner tops down
jarvis
[Applause]
[Applause]
third down
jackson fires and that will be
intercepted in the end zone
by karen johnson
the buffalo bills have all of buffalo
rocking like they haven't been rocking
in 20-something years
always put the money on me oh beautiful
we're good this is what we wanted it for
rogers
[Applause]
hell yeah great job man slow motion for
you right now
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody is bigger fun than me papi let's
go
let's go brady let's go we eating w's
we see you at lambeau but if this is it
for drew brees
this will be a sour taste love you man
you too yeah
man i'll be in touch tom brady good job
man
good job man it is official
the chiefs will not have patrick mahomes
for the rest of this game he is
out with a concussion chief lead 22-17
they have third and 14 with chad henny
at quarterback
you're trying to get this first down
[Applause]
it's going to be short there's no play
just look at the body language
there is a place
[Applause]
[Music]
dad baby let's go
anything is possible i don't know
another coach in the league that would
have been that aggressive
that's what i'm talking about anything
is possible how about this
buffalo we will see you next week get
the camera on me dog
that game ended when i needed me to move
[Music]
and i'm gonna clean it up because this
is gonna be my lucky shirt
we're gonna do the big ones i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna put them in the
dryer i'm gonna wear it next week